coal powered us through the industrial
revolution
now it's powering us to an environmental
catastrophe
so why is it so hard to kick
the simplest answer is because it's the
status quo most nations national grids
are built to use it and many of the
world's economies are supported by its
production
the technology does exist to move away
from coal
some countries have managed to stop
using it entirely and now rely on the
sun wind water nuclear or gas for power
but huge sways of the world still use
coal in fact in 2019 27
of the world's energy came from it
and renewable energy can have huge
upfront costs and may not be as reliable
as the old coal-fired power stations
the problem is coal is dirty mining it
like they are behind me damages local
ecosystems and pollutes air and water
but burning it is even worse
when it burns coal produces more co2
than any other fossil fuel
that in turn has a greenhouse effect
around the planet and causes it to heat
up
who's the biggest coal addict of all
china
at a time when most developed nations
are decommissioning their minds shutting
down their coal-fired power stations
china is going in the opposite direction
it is building coal-fired power plants
at a rate that outpaces the rest of the
world combined
last year china brought 38.4 gigawatts
of new coal-fired power into operation
that's more than three times what was
brought online anywhere else
in 2019 nearly 58 of its power came from
and china's huge reliance on coal is one
of the reasons it emitted 27 of the
world's greenhouse gases in 2019
but it isn't just china's problem
in australia coal is mined in every
state and in one month in 2021 the
government approved plans for three new
coal mine developments
the uk government is currently deciding
whether to open its first deep coal mine
in 30 years
and after the fukushima nuclear disaster
of 2011 countries like germany who were
moving away from coal decommissioned
their nuclear power plants because of
safety fears which means they went
straight back to being reliant on coal
one reason that coal is so hard to kick
is that growing economies need a lot of
power and coal is a reliable and
affordable way of getting it the chinese
government for example wants the economy
to grow by six percent every year
one of their top concerns about reaching
that target is not having enough energy
to drive the economy
and for those in power coal is a safe
bet a coal-fired power station will
deliver reliable affordable power to
your voters without needing to rely on a
sunny day or windy seas
so for the world to kick its coal habit
it's going to take a massive shift in
that status quo
[Music]